this is the oceans Twilight Zone more
than 30 meters below the surface
coral reefs still flourish in the gloom
but these deep reefs could be under
threat from a powerful force
hurricanes scientists have long known
that shallow reefs are vulnerable to
hurricanes with corals torn apart as the
winds stir on the scene but the reefs of
The Twilight Zone have been assumed to
be protected from the worst effects
these deeper reefs have also been
thought to provide a temporary refuge
for shallow reef species which could
shelter in the deeper water but new
research is telling a different story
scientists in Puerto Rico have been
studying reefs both before and after
Hurricane Maria a particularly violent
storm they've already shown that the
hurricane caused currents and upwellings
deep into the twilight zone next they
plan to assess damage to the deeper
corals directly in Maria's path the deep
reaching effects of strong hurricanes
would be bad news for species on the
hunt for somewhere to weather the storm
of course coral reefs have been
surviving hurricanes for millennia but
extreme weather events are getting more
common as the climate changes human
activity is also causing ocean
acidification and warming this can lead
to diseases in coral bleaching and
recent research suggests that deeper
reefs could be just as vulnerable as
shallow ones coral reefs provide
coastlines with a line of defense
against storms so losing this delicate
resource could add yet more pressure to
regions already devastated by the
effects of climate change
[Music]